welcome to this video covering the games
or this is just one game in this video
of the 8th route of the candidates the
game we're going to look at his Cromley
kagan son Drake in the duel of the two
winners of yesterday while under aching
this one a fine game against to Paolo
who basically self-destructed crumley
come one an absolutely amazing game
against Mammadyarov way probably was
lost just two or three moves on before
the game ended in his favor and
immensely complicated game that really
am was was keep in the tournament it's
now crown [ __ ] still in contention and
if he would have lost the game he would
basically be out of the competition so
let's see what is happening here
certainly again we're chronic wants to
push us white he needs to win somewhere
and the white game some he needs to do
something okay what do we have sloth
defense kayaking is playing the cello
nenko he had played in a 6-line earlier
this tournament so something that could
have been expected and after g3 however
draken took 20 minutes and then played
b5 and this is completely completely out
of this world to be honest when I was
watching this I couldn't believe what's
happening simply because I mean you he's
black he plays Kramnik ramnik is a
default player and if you look at the
latest games that chrome nick is played
against the Chavo nenko he played g3 in
a very involved game for instance
against Luke McShane in the 2012 london
classics yet played g3 so this is a move
that you absolutely have to prepare
against and no one dragon is taking 20
minutes on move 5 and then plays b5
that's really amazing what did he
prepare
it's a bit bit strange is he really
doing this over the board and not
preparing at all I cannot believe that
yeah it's a very strange I guess Kramnik
was also bit puzzled Marty soon but of
all it is doing okay in itself be five
is not a terrible move um the main main
the continuation is actually to capture
on c4 and then cromley get played a form
in this earlier game that i mentioned e6
Bishop g2 c5 and we get to a typical on
line that normally arises from five a
form and there's a bit a bit similar to
the Catalan and therefore certainly
suits a chrome legs style Black has
other moves on b5 it's just one of them
but it's a play with 1b5 b3 and now
Bishop f5 played band Reagan when I am
had a study of the chabanenko Slav on
for a video series that I'm producing
for is SC in German language I actually
recommended this move but just also i'm
quite solid to black you just continue
with the developing and something like
that is probably probably going to
happen with a fairly solid position for
black under against me forever Bishop f5
is not bad at all of the slim just
developing Bishop g2 and now he played a
an interesting which is very rare in
this position I'm play tonight reform
and he six is the somewhat soft
suggesting obvious move but well he
didn't want to go down i'm not i'm not
quite sure why exactly maybe he was um
yeah he wasn't liking something like
night edge for to happen maybe not in
this precise position but maybe even in
this precise position where white will
get the bishop pair or you need to move
from again possibly
you don't want to allow the capture on a
5 this is a belief in this special case
not to grid yeah he played 94 and this I
mean it did I understand that from a
positional point of view this can be
good but it takes lots of time the idea
is that wider no takes you can also
uncover that like like this this for
instance had been played by Yvonne
sokoloff the strong Bosnian Dutch Grand
Master and something like that happened
in a game against see Grandmaster
Simonian 2011 and this is quite similar
to the game the difference is that the
bishop now is on c3 and in the game it
went to another place we will see that
soon Kramnik took and castled and maybe
this is more interesting in comparison
and idea could be that if black now
place the normal looking ecigs that
white can actually play 95 hem and this
seems to be somewhat more comfortable
for why'd you look at this yeah black
cannot play this because it's hanging
and after Bishop d6 which looks
perfectly normal why it has the
interesting continuation inform
intending a quick 3g form and you note
that you notice that what really has the
better development here like ISM in
slight slight roll him he probably
didn't want the night to come to e5 so
this is why I drank and played 97 yeah
the whole position here is a bit it's
also matter of tempe in a way if it
would be blacks move here or white would
play now somewhat less to the point
let's say he plays Bishop b2 for example
then after he six black is in perfectly
fine shape he has established this
Bishop only for which is very useful
simply because it hinders whites expand
in the center if ya how is white going
to make any progress here you can of
course needs the night yeah but
something like that I'm glad to exchange
pieces and be perfectly fine and the
other ideas that white can play here and
then 92 then you will capture the right
moment and just say okay I've got the
perfectly sound porn structure or porn
SIA on light squares I have a dark
squared bishop to go with that and
whites bishop on b2 is not not so great
this is the idea to put the bishop on
only form and yeah what's the specific
of this position at this move and this
is very strong that chronic has this
available now the movie 6 simply loses
so much time that you cannot afford that
let's save and now 95 or the capture
yeah and here white is simply click on
the C file e6 is not a good movie played
g6 to avoid that but have a look steaks
and Queen d2 yeah very good post for the
Queen it controls crucial squares it
might switch over to the King side at
the right moment and that of course
prepares action on the sea farm or this
is perfectly logical and now Bishop h3y
it's very hard to make any sort of
progress without this move and I guess
it's correct played by Crom neck to play
that yeah and raking took this this is
basically basically forced if black is
not taking white will retreat or let's
say remove the bishop to some others and
so on the square even you want us move
to consider and maybe use it on the on
the queenside you must you must get rid
of this especially considering that the
C file is open you really want nights to
disappear from the
so the night is not appearing on a on
those of any of those weeks square some
very understandable and now rupee ATM
okay you'd like to play six but this
again was not possible due to the a3
bishop so rupee eight yeah how to assess
this position it it looks really
comfortable for white it really does the
next couple of moves look completely
completely logical to me and I have a
hard time to suggest any improvements on
Roxy six now e6 displayed may be here in
this position you could try to improve
White's play maybe i'm not i'm not sure
really but this is a possible
opportunity like um is intending at this
move attacking on d4 and not to air to a
bite on f3 it's a double attack on those
to pawn weaknesses and maybe white has
yeah maybe white has some alternative
that actually does not sacrifice a pawn
chronic sacrifice the porn basically and
i think it was i was okay it's not like
it was a mistake what he did but maybe
there is some way to get the position
that he actually got without without
giving away upon that i'm not not sure
how this might be possible you can play
you can play relatively passive move
like Bishop b2 at some point and just
say okay I've got to see file anyway
something like that you know this
renders Queen f6 a bit pointless this
white will cover this pawn maybe maybe
even with this move covering both and
controlling the sea farm yeah maybe this
is an idea i don't know i mean what what
he did is perfectly logical to me the
the porno on f3 cannot be so important
he played this and Dragon plate Queen f6
this
also what you must do other other than
that lucky does not have any play you
should really get this pawn and and
defend your position not being on equal
material but like here with the next
report so this is perfectly okay queenie
r 6 plate and Kramnik of course took the
seventh-ranked yeah and this night
retreated to f8 it's very understandable
Luke the aide was also possible but it
looks a bit weird to possibly expose
your queen side like that um native
eight is the normal move in my book yeah
and now he played Bishop c5 yeah what
what can you do how will deform it's a
bit early to give away so he covered
this some important poem yeah and now
black really should take and did take it
on f3 yeah um is there something else a
black can try something like that but
what are you doing now queen is attacked
and the rook is at exel it loses
material this is just the best move take
the pawn yeah and term Luke c3 it looks
perfectly normal the Queen went to age
five yeah okay you could look at this
move but it sort of looks like it runs
into a later okay of three so it's
probably not particularly great Queen h5
is also gaining the certain porn on the
bishop and it almost yeah I'm not sure
it forces White's reply but it invites
white suppliant chronic plated he played
g-form gaining this temple on the Queen
Queen edge form no choice and Queen f1
this sir all this looks completely
completely logical to me whew I'm could
easily imagine myself playing those
moves don't have any any
apparent improvements or objections or
whatever and wrote here it is
interesting to to check what kind of
possibilities both sides have and Drake
in here played the move f6 yeah I mean
okay you need to do something about the
main threat um yeah what else was there
he had two alternatives to consider this
you can dismiss really quickly well
white will crush crash through an f7 so
not playable at all um but there was f5
this month was an alternative and to be
honest I'm not one hungry prison sure
what white should do against it it's I
think this position is one of those
where white will have a compensation no
matter what for one porn at least but
it's not so clear to determine what is
actually the the best movie em I had a
look at Brooke p7 intending Queen c7 is
a very direct approach after that black
can try the sharp movie 5 an interesting
try you know the ideas that after the
capture there is 96 or even busier me
five both seems to be good however after
Lucas sorry after f5 rupee 75 White has
the move Queen a3 which is surprisingly
strong it detects on d5 and what does
black smooth now if you go evo I'll just
go here and it turns out that you had
this type of position like is forced to
take and with the bishop activated white
will have a very good compensation for
the pawn it's nothing to fear here at
all for white
if videos 96cm sort of trying to solve
things technically white can take and
take care and it turns out that the rook
in South helping in defense on the
third-ranked this seems to be okay for
white it's very complicated obviously
with alternatives for both sides but
rupee c7 now seems seems like playable
to me um there's also Queen g3 here
which is maybe the the most conservative
move its leading to I guess a decent
game for white um what does a black
smooth now if you go back here you even
have to consider G files looks a bit bit
ugly so the capture is probably the way
to go yet here white always has this
idea of capturing on the right moment on
f8 and getting ecigs back like this and
this and this is very likely going to
end in the draw because white has really
enough activity two to get the get the
draw but not much more than that f5 an
interesting movie played f6 which is
also quite quite okay I mean there's
nothing that nothing great that white
can do here he played Bishop e7 chrome
licked it and yeah you can you can try
other moves 26 for example you can try
try to enter with the Queen but we're
actually do you go it's not like you
have access to those squares but I can
even play you five and just claim that
the queen is doing nothing here now okay
can go here but it didn't really have
ripped your any big benefits I think
Bishop e7 is perfectly
name to be honest it also sets a little
trap not a difficult trap but yeah if
black now plays g5 why does instantly
winning with bishop at six this is quite
neat check checkmate an immediate made
very nice yeah g fiber says an insane
move what else your age five is a move
that needs to be needs to be look at
looked at but it's not clear to me if
it's really threatening so much white
can even consider to just play nothing
move and ask like what are you doing
there's a fun drawing line with e five
tags 96 and queen are three this
position he actually is very very tough
for black to play as wide as threatening
to just win outright and it seems that
he probably needs to do that too to
secure at least the draw him check check
check this seems to be the best line and
it it's a perpetual check i just think
that in this whole position there is a
fine balance between the the positional
compensation that white has and the
material is just about equal i believe
um however h5 was maybe maybe the the
better move compared to what and Drake
indeed he played Queen to g5 and chrome
leg went to g3 um yeah he also could
have considered to take but the question
is if this is really helping white white
much especially considering that after
Bishop takes a g5 this is a bit
misplaced here however after the capture
something like that it's just a pawn and
probably it's still enough compensation
compared to the game or ever Queen g3 is
just the better move and this is because
of a very specific threat if black now
is playing nothing move I'm going to
play a form and now it's going to be
very embarrassing for the Queen no not a
sight you want to want to have us black
yeah you only have one move after Queen
g3 this is Queen d2 and I believe here
is the point where the game is really am
coming to a point where draws almost
unavoidable and this is after
chrome-like has played the move g5 p.m.
it seems that the move Queen III was a
lot better and after that maybe white
can even try to press in this position
it's quite remarkable like a mistake
there is no other square root it takes
takes and now for example at 5pm I don't
really see how black can avoid the
smooth want to activate you on f8 Bishop
gentium maybe white can just continue
with King f2 end yeah improved slightly
the the problem here from blacks point
of view is you don't really have any
constructive things to do White has this
compensation and yeah what what is what
exactly is black smooth him whatever I
blacks moves here white can try to
improve slightly like doubling on the
7th things like that you can you can try
and it's it's not so apparent what black
is going to do here this is certainly a
very very good compensation for the pawn
the computer is actually giving white an
advantage of almost half a pawn sounds
quite a lot to me but yeah what what
exactly is black playing here very very
difficult and there are some things that
that might happen to blacken in very
short order if he's not is not cautious
um let's say for example something like
that check oops check the widest winning
immediately of course this was very a
they're very accor perative but not
untypical of this position where white
is so active it seems that here black
has some problems to solve I wouldn't
very much like to play that as black
yeah kramnik played g5 the the more
direct continuation and after greene
takes we also get a position where wider
certainly as compensation but it's
simply two pawns now black has gotten
the default born and why does not in so
much control as in the position that i
showed before there he had to really add
a center d4 and III and this is gone now
yeah so what about this is this a bad
position for chronic i don't think so
it's still so active and white always
has this idea to play Bishop age six or
to e7 e seven there and then take on f8
at the right moment and then regain on
e6 the pawn luck has absolutely no way
to to unwind from this idea they
continued of course a bit kim ji soo kim
ji to was still important if white would
take now check he has this problem on f2
so he plays kingi to first and black
simply has no
no way to to improve his position he
played a for ya now after Bishop after
the capture I'm sorry and now here they
agreed to a draw as we now after bushes
at six King here and rook c8 will come
to a completely check that position or
widest protecting on a tomb and there's
simply nothing going on yeah um a draw
in this game it doesn't change the
standings very much chronic servant he
would have liked to to to get something
get a win but I'm draken played a very
good defense I believe he really didn't
allow much Queen III was maybe an idea
to continue the game in this position
where he went g5 here Queenie three but
other than that I I think a very correct
and and the deserved draw for both
players yeah this means that chrome leg
stays on +1 and isn't within striking
distance of the the tournament elite and
undressing stays on minus one not
brilliant but okay there it was not that
he was a big favorite to win the event
so minus one is not not really bad for
him all right I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this game thanks for
watching